from bloomberg quick take i'm madison
mills
the world officially recorded 1 million
deaths from coven 19
and some experts say fatalities could be
closer to double
that number this comes as we're heading
into the winter months and could see an
additional uptake in cases joining us to
discuss this and more is dr tom frieden
the former director of the cdc
and the president and ceo of resolve to
save lives dr frieden thank you so much
for making time for us today
great to be with you uh just to start us
off i'm wondering how
you're holding up and how you're doing
this is a really tough time for everyone
well i think one of the things that we
recognize
is that this is the teachable moment
that we are all connected and the more
we learn that lesson the more we're
going to do better
looking all around the world we see some
countries doing really well
and others including sadly the us not
doing so well
over the past few days we've not just
hit the official 1 million
mark for deaths globally but actually it
could be
twice that relatively easily globally
given under reporting in many countries
of asia and latin america
and uh here in new york city uh where
our organization has its home we're
seeing a resurgence in some
communities and the risk of uh wider
spread
covet is going to be here for the longer
term
and we're going to have to adapt and
chip away at the risk with a series of
measures
so i think for those of us in public
health it's both
a moment of crisis but it's a moment of
great frustration
because we see countries all over the
world not listening to public health
not following public health guidance and
that backfiring
and then the same mistake happening
again so we're hopeful
that we'll see uh better responses we're
thinking
some players will be doing a good job in
some places globally doing a good job
and dr freddie and you mentioned new
york's positivity rate can you talk to
me about what can be done to combat that
spike
what we're seeing in new york city is a
rapid increase
in some religious communities and there
are communities that are
not well connected to the government and
i have quite a bit of crowding and so i
think there is a near
inevitability that there will be more
spread in these communities what's not
clear
is how widely it will spread around the
united states
and so what what do you think is
something that new york is doing that
other states could learn sort of not to
do
i'm thinking specifically about indoor
dining just opened up in the city
um we've seen some outdoor dining
practices that
i've heard you mentioned are not
necessarily the safest can you talk
about that a bit
i think what's really important is
that we take measures that are specific
to the communities
and what we're seeing here is usually
with infectious diseases you don't have
one epidemic
you have many epidemics so whether it's
meat packing
factories or agricultural workers
or a religious community or
different groups that have both crowding
and less connection with
the government and rest of society
that's a vulnerable
location and you need to work in advance
to make sure
that you have as much connection with
folks there as you can
so that you can draw on the strength of
that community to
try to stop transmission prevent it from
occurring
stop it when it does occur and really
engage the community and address the
needs of people
living within the community that may
sound soft but really
that's the only way to succeed and how
concerned are you about
cases getting a lot bigger when we head
into the winter months and people are
forced inside
um every season is coveted season
there were some people saying it would
be less in the summer i was dubious
about that i said that back in march and
april
however in winter months we do tend to
see
colder months more spread as more people
are indoors
less sunlight less ventilation
we're not exactly sure of all of the
reasons but we do
tend to see an increase in colder months
so it's certainly a risk
we're seeing outbreaks in university
settings
we're seeing outbreaks in essential
workplaces
so this pandemic is far from over
and there's no fairy tale ending to the
pandemic
even a vaccine is not going to make it
go away overnight we're going to have to
chip away at that risk with
what we call the 3ws wear a mask watch
your distance
wash your hands with strategic closures
doesn't mean everything has to be closed
but bars bad idea lots of people
small space poor ventilation no masks
loud voices that's basically a formula
for the spread of covet if covet is
there same with choirs and choruses
this is a very efficient way of
spreading covet indoors
so i think we need to get smarter about
strategic closures that limit the damage
to the economy
but at the same time limit the risk that
someone will die
from a social event you mentioned bars
as a no-go for for
handling this pandemic but i'm curious
in general
what people can do who are trying to be
cautious and do the right thing but
are also kind of experiencing pandemic
fatigue and may be having some negative
mental health effects from staying
inside um
how can people find that balance of
staying safe and
sane during this time right well we're
all sick and tired
of this virus but unfortunately the
virus is not tired of making us
sick and so we have to be careful but we
can adapt
first off go outside outside is
great sunlight healthy more vitamin d
fights infections good ventilation
improves your mood
so spend time outside it's massively
safer
than indoors and it is good for your
health and your mental health
and the risk is drastically lower than
indoor spaces um so that i guess is
first and foremost second
it's important to have routines that you
follow things that you enjoy doing try
to figure out how to get those back
whether that's a book club online or
figuring out how to do
physical activity safely or
going about important patterns or
rituals that you have that are important
to you
and finding people you can talk with and
share with
online social events it sounds strange
but
you know it's it's better than nothing
and uh
outdoor events also important also
within bubbles
uh being able to find a small group of
people
if you can if this fits your environment
who are not having contact with others
but can have
contact with each other one of the
things we do in my family is
my mother's 91 she lives alone and what
we'll do is
one of us kids will quarantine
essentially for 14 days then we'll go
spend some time with her or she'll
quarantine then she'll go spend time
with my brother so
there are ways to get through it it's
frustrating
but um you know keep in mind that this
two will
pass we can't say when it's not going to
be quick
or simple uh even with a vaccine it
wouldn't be quick or simple
but it will pass and the key is to stick
with it and
to emphasize those things that are good
you know being able to
not have to deal with the commute good
thing for a lot of people
uh having other opportunities to
interact and
new ways to experience not great but
but at least uh there's a lot that we
can do
to have fulfilling activity
and as we head into the winter months
another problem that's popping up is flu
season of course and people are just
getting
colds and similar viruses because
of being outside in the cold i'm
wondering if you can talk through some
of the defining factors of
covid that can help people differentiate
between a simple cold and covet 19
symptoms
well you really can't um the the cold
and covet are very similar the flu and
covet are really very similar
but first off get a flu shot it's the
single most important thing you can do
to protect
yourself against flu second uh
one of the things that we say about flu
is that the only thing predictable about
flu is that it's unpredictable
uh but having said that i would predict
that that we're probably not going to
have a bad flu season in this calendar
year
people are staying in too much there's
not that much travel
so it would be quite surprising if we
saw a lot of flu they're not
seeing flu in the southern hemisphere
when they usually do
so it's likely that we're not going to
see flu at least through this year but
by all means get a flu shot
and this is just one more reason to be
careful about coving the things we do
for covid washing our hands wearing a
mask
washing our distance are going to reduce
other infections as well so even if
coveted
isn't around they do some good
fair enough and we are heading into an
election on november 3rd i'm wondering
what your take is on how the president
has handled the pandemic so far
well i think there's not the slightest
doubt that the u.s
has been a laggard that our response has
failed and because of that we have
one of the higher death rates in the
world because of that
we have many more jobs and lives lost
and
could have been lost otherwise there
really is a lot more we can do
to be safer to have an organized
response to have
structured communication about it to
tell people what they can do
to help people address problems to scale
up
a comprehensive approach to have clear
indicators
the list of things that are not being
done well
by the us government really goes on and
on and on and if you if you look at
places as varied as iceland germany
austria denmark taiwan
hong kong singapore rwanda
senegal you're talking about places that
have 5
10 50 100 times lower death rates
than the united states we really could
have done
so much better it didn't have to be this
bad
and we of course are heading into the
debate tonight
is there anything that you are hoping to
hear from either candidate that would
give you
a little bit of peace about how the
country could handle coven 19.
you know i wish we would all recognize
that we are all connected
that infection in
any individual in any group in any part
of the country
is a risk everywhere and we're all in it
together
and the more we recognize that the
better off we'll be
the more anyone divides us
the more the virus can continue to
conquer us
the more we recognize that we're in it
together the more we can
push the virus back and get more of our
lives and our livelihoods back
and we do have a really young audience
here at quick take do you have a
specific message for young people
about their involvement in this uptick
in numbers
you know i'm encouraged despite some
media reports the vast majority of
people young and old
are really concerned about making others
sick and understand
that even if you don't have any symptoms
at all or feel only mildly ill from it
you could end up infecting someone else
and they could die from it none of us
want
that on our conscience none of us want
that to happen and
just keep in mind this will pass it may
feel like forever
but it's not it's going to pass um
it'll be better by late 2021 a year from
now
and within the next few years uh we'll
be to a new normal
things will be different maybe we'll be
used to not going out when we're sick
why should you expose other people when
you're sick stay home
take care of yourself and hopefully
we'll be in a world that recognizes our
common humanity
and is better to one another because of
it you mentioned
2021 uh what is your current thinking
around a timeline for a vaccine
we don't know anyone who says they know
what's going to happen doesn't know
enough
we don't have any proof that a vaccine
works is effective
it's manufactured can be delivered we're
guardedly optimistic there will be
vaccines
but a vaccine is not going to bring a
fairy tale ending
to this pandemic it's going to be one
more tool in our toolbox
and we have to keep all of those tools
sharp that includes masking up
testing tracing quarantining and
vaccination
it needs to be rolled out in a way that
builds trust so that people will
actually take
it if we have the greatest vaccine in
the world but people don't trust it it's
not going to work
and that's really important uh
factor to keep in mind like we provide
information
about the vaccine and we are heading
into the holidays as well
are you concerned that people who are
traveling to be with loved ones over the
holidays might
end up leading to an uptick in cases as
well
i think travel isn't so much the concern
but what we
are seeing is get togethers with lots of
people
indoors what you want to do is try to
limit the number of people coming from
different places
and congregating indoors because that's
essentially the formula for spread think
of it
as an equation number of people not
wearing masks
rate of cover in the community level of
ventilation
and duration of time you put those
factors together
you're going to get spread of covid dr
freedon a final question for you you've
mentioned it a little bit but what is
giving you
hope right now what makes you hopeful
that we
we won't see another million deaths
in 2020 i hope this will
really illustrate that we're all
connected that within the u.s
we need a much stronger public health
system
we need to fund it we need to support it
we need to be guided by science and
globally
that all of our faiths are really bound
up with one another that the more
we can find diseases when and where they
first emerge stop them soon whenever
that's possible
and prevent them wherever possible not
only will countries be
safer but we'll be safer we can be
stronger there and safer here
and that commonality that common purpose
and common fate and common humanity i
hope
will lead us to a safer and a healthier
world
dr frieden thank you so much for making
time for us today and for those of you
watching please continue to follow our
coverage on covid19
on all social platforms at bloomberg
quick take and thanks again have a great
day
thank you